we've been huge fans of you since the
beginnings of Cameron ever since you
start as both Liv and Maddie on the hit
Disney Channel show really hope you
don't drop this we love cheers you know
it weighs about as much as a baby girl
we loved your acting
then in descendants you showed us how
great of a singer you are too we have
loved watching you go up and find
yourself the image you've created is
inspiring we can't wait to see even more
from you in the future
dove Cameron is one of these biggest
celebs right now but how exactly did she
rise to superstar status keep watching
to find out all about doves rise to fame
tragic backstory dove Cameron's real
name is chloe Celeste Haas terman she is
from Seattle Washington and she's had to
overcome a totally tragic event dove was
super close with both of her parents
growing up she started acting on stage
at age 8 sadly her dad passed away when
she was just 15 years old he called her
dove as a nickname the early days dove
started acting in Hollywood way back in
2012
she knew her dad wouldn't want her to
quit her dreams like a lot of star stuff
started with a lot of small roles she
was a guest star on a lot of TV shows
she was on two episodes of the 2012
series shameless she appeared on an
episode of the drama The Mentalist it
wasn't long before Disney Channel saw
how talented she was and once she joined
the Disney Channel family Doug quickly
became a household name and the rest is
pretty much history Liv and Maddie
Disney Channel cast stuff in her own TV
show in 2013 Liv and Maddie which was
originally called bits and pieces was a
huge hit this really put dub in the
limelight among young fans she played
both Liv and Maddie to identical twins
who are totally different it really
showed how talented dove is as an
actress because she could play two
different characters and be believable
as both this was doves breakthrough role
[Music]
cloud9 the producers at Disney Channel
knew that they had something special and
um
the year after Liv and Maddie first
aired dove scored a lead role in her
first-ever Disney Channel Original Movie
dove starred in cloud nine it was a
drama with sport and romance she played
a competitive snowboarder it was
different from anything else she had
done and her fans were super impressed
the success is what led her to her
biggest role rotten to the core in 2015
Disney Channel released one of their
most successful original movies ever
descendants was all about the children
of Disney Villains
what I'm not going to some boarding
school filled to the brim with prissy
pink princesses Duff Cameron was cast in
the lead role as mal the daughter of
Maleficent
she blew everyone away this movie
revealed that she was not only a
talented actress but an incredible
singer and she rode the descendant
success for four years she got even
better in the last two movies love story
dove was in the public eye when she
started dating her Liv and Maddie
co-star Ryan McCartney they were really
young when they got engaged in 2016 but
it wasn't meant to last dub then fell in
love with Thomas Doherty from
descendants - these two stars are super
happy together they even have matching
tattoos as of 2019 they seem really
serious Thomas has even gone as far to
say that she's the one want to know
what's in Dubbs future keep watching to
find out I always look forward to our
Chuck's ears please marvel and more dev
was never exclusive to Disney Channel
she made her way into the mainstream
with roles in Marvel shows chief I drew
be in agents of shield then she played
Gwen Stacy and ghost spider in several
marvel rising series she also played a
beauty pageant queen in dumplin's and
voiced Ella in the Angry Birds movie
tear stuff has definitely become a
mainstream actress finding herself after
The Descendants franchise ended dove
really needed to find yourself sometimes
stars have a hard time shaking their
Disney Channel image but dove is super
authentic
isn't having that problem hey I'm me
again she has taken time to figure out
who she is and she took some drastic
steps she cleared out her entire
Instagram before her first single
dropped she's wise beyond her years and
loves reading and writing new music
doves a talented singer she worked hard
to get some original music out after the
release of descendants three and her two
singles did not disappoint her fans she
released blood shots and waste they're
both amazing songs with a lot of emotion
behind them she also released two fresh
edgy music videos for each of these
singles her fans are anxiously awaiting
more music the future so what's next for
dub dub is working on new music because
that's her true passion but don't worry
she's not leaving the acting scene
anytime soon she recently starred in the
stage production of the light in the
Piazza she has said she has several
other things lined up but we don't know
what they are just yet definitely 23 so
she's a lot of time to figure out what
she wants to do with her life and
clearly she's a jack-of-all-trades so
when it comes to her anything is
possible
do you love learning everything there is
to know about your favorite celeb
sweetie to subscribe to the things and
title notifications for all the latest
videos if you're watching on your mobile
make sure your settings are set to allow
YouTube notifications that's a wrap what
is your favorite thing about dove
Cameron let us know in the comment
sections dove Cameron's rise to fame
thanks for watching give this video a
big thumbs up if you love dove Cameron
you